Salut. Dans une précédente vidéo,
je vous avais posé quelques questions.
Pour la série "Expérience Mentale".
C'était la deuxième collecte de données,
vous l'avez ici, si vous ne l'aviez pas vue.
Vous avez été 65 535 à répondre
et j'ai enfin traité toutes ces données.
On va voir ce qu'on peut en tirer,
quelles conclusions on peut en faire
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
de toutes ces réponses là.
Générique !
[Musique du générique]
L'idée principale de ce test
était de collecter des données
parfois réfléchies, et parfois spontanées,
en demandant l'âge des personnes
pour voir les réponses qui arrivait le plus.
D'une, pour voir, comme
dans le titre de cette vidéo
si on est des clones ou pas.
Mais surtout pour comprendre
les automatismes de notre cerveau.
Dans la dernière vidéo,
que je vous mets ici,
je vous parlais de l'effet de Stroop.
Et on a vu qu'on avait des traitements cognitifs
un peu programmés qui prenaient le pas.
Je me suis dit que ce serait intéressant
de voir avec vous, comme vous êtes nombreux,
si on peut en tirer des conclusions,
voir quelque chose, des liens...
Alors, je vous le dis tout de suite,
j'ai très peu tenu compte de l'âge
parce que je me suis rendu compte,
en traitant les données,
durant ce 1 mois et demi...
1 mois et demi... à traiter les données.
Je ne me suis pas rendu compte
de l'ampleur du travail qu'il y avait...
Je disais : je me suis rendu compte que
l'âge n'avait pas d'incidence,
quasi pas d'incidence
sur les réponses.
A part à un endroit :
dans la première question.
La première question c'était :
"Quel est votre film préféré ? "
La tendance que j'ai vue,
par rapport à l'âge,
c'était que plus la personne est jeune
plus son film préféré est l'un
des derniers films d'action
voire de Super-Héros
qui serait sorti dans
la dernière année.
C'est quelque chose que j'avais
pressenti, moi, dans la vie courante,
et ça c'est confirmé largement.
Les films qui arrivent en tête
sont plutôt des films de garçon.
Ou, en tout cas, on aurait tendance
à dire que c'est des films de garçon,
parce que plein de filles
aiment ces films aussi.
Et ce n'est pas très étonnant quand
on voit que ma communauté Youtube
est, à 75%, composée de mecs.
J'aimerais bien qu'on équilibre,
d'ailleurs, un jour...
Les 3 premiers films préférés
des 65 535 personnes
sont, dans l'ordre :
Harry Potter, Avatar
et Deadpool.
Ces 3 films valent 7%
des réponses que j'ai eues.
Donc, à peu près, 4500 personnes.
Ensuite, dans le Top10,
nous avons :
en 4ème, Fight Club
en 5ème, Star Wars
après : Inception, Batman,
La ligne verte, Pulp Fiction
et, enfin, Titanic.
Ces 7 films là, donc dans mon
classement de 4 à 10,
représentent, eux, 10% des
réponses, donc 6500 réponses.
Après, pour tout le reste,
il n'y avait pas de tendance majeure.
Mais ça veut dire que,
si vous rencontrez quelqu'un
et que vous lui demandez
quel est son film préféré,
il y a quand même 17%
de chance
que ce soit l'un de ces 10 films.
C'est pas mal.
Mais dans les autres questions
on a des statistiques encore plus hallucinantes...
Toutes les autres questions
que j'ai posées, à la suite,
avaient ce point commun qu'il
fallait répondre sans réfléchir.
Je vous ai donc demandé,
en question numéro 2,
de me citer le nom
d'un Super Héros
en anecdote marrante, j'ai 3 personnes
qui m'ont répondu 20h37...
que 3 personnes...
me fassent la même
réponse chelou...
Ça c'était étrange.
Je sens une conspiration.
Alors là, c'était beaucoup plus
tranché que pour les films.
Spontanément, quand je vous ai
demandé un Super-Héros,
35% d'entre vous m'ont répondu
Batman.
35% sur 65 535 personnes,
c'est énorme !
30% m'ont répondu
Superman.
Je ne l'attendais pas aussi haut
dans le classement.
Ensuite, 10% Deadpool
et 10% Spiderman.
Ils sont 3ème à égalité.
Mais vraiment à égalité,
à quelque... vingtaine de personne près.
Et 15% m'ont donné
d'autres noms de Super-Héros.
Et ça c'est très intéressant,
par exemple, si vous voulez faire
un tour de mentalisme à quelqu'un,
un tour un petit peu bluffant,
vous pouvez préparer
quelque chose,
en sachant qu'il y a
85% de chance
qu'on vous réponde :
Batman, Superman,
Spiderman ou Deadpool.
La 3ème question c'est que vous deviez
me donner un nombre ou un chiffre
entre 0 et 100.
Celle-ci, je vous le dis franchement,
pour moi, je pensais que c'était une question morte
et un petit peu inutile.
Mais... il s'est révélé
certaines choses...
Certains d'entre vous on voulu
me faire marrer en mettant des -1,
ou des π, des 3,14
des 3,14 15...
et une insulte au passage...
On ne sait pas pourquoi.
Mais alors là,
tenez vous bien :
20 000 d'entre vous ont répondu
un chiffre entre 0 et 9.
Presque 10 0000,
9500 et quelques,
ont répondu 42.
Alors là, je ne sais pas trop
comment réagir.
C'est à dire que 42, c'est quelque chose,
moi, quand je demande un chiffre,
qui est souvent revenu.
Sur tous les âges, toutes les catégories
sociaux-culturelles, tous les genres...
Mais, vous et moi, on sait que 42
c'est... c'est La Réponse...
La Réponse à la grande question
sur la Vie, sur l'Univers...
Pourtant, ceux qui m'ont répondu 42,
moi, dans ma vie courante,
ne connaissent pas forcément la référence
de guide du voyageur galactique
Et quand j'ai lu pourquoi l'auteur
avait choisi 42, à l'époque,
il dit qu'il n'y avait rien
de spécial derrière,
que c'était le nombre qui lui paraissait
le plus aléatoire possible, le plus neutre possible.
Et je me demande si notre cerveau
n'est pas configuré pour dire 42
quand il cherche un nombre
complétement aléatoire.
Bon, ça n'a pas grande valeur scientifique,
hein, ce que je vous dis là,
c'est juste mon interprétation
et mon ressenti.
Et d'une manière générale
les nombres, ensuite,
avaient, à peu près,
la même statistique de sortie.
Sauf un :
Qui n'a été dit que 3 fois.
82 était mal aimé ou...
j'en sais rien.
Mais c'était étonnant.
J'aurais même été agréablement surpris
qu'il y en ait un qui ne soit pas cité du tout.
Sur 65000 réponses,
ça aurait été intéressant.
Il n'y avait que 100 réponses
possibles, alors que la prochaine question
il y avait beaucoup moins
de réponses possibles,
puisque je vous demandais
de donner, spontanément,
une des notes...
Do, ré, mi, fa, sol, la, si.
Là encore, il y a eu des choses marrantes.
Par exemple, il y a 8 d'entre vous
qui m'ont répondu :
"Come as You Are"
Ce qui voudrait dire que, tous ceux
qui n'ont pas compris la question,
sont des Fans de "Come as You Are"
de Nirvana... j'en sais rien.
Bref.
Sinon, quasiment 86% des réponses,
85,9% des réponses,
ont englobé les deux notes suivantes :
le Do et le La.
DO : 44% des réponses.
Et La, presque 42% des réponses.
Et les autres sont,
à peu près, équilibrées.
Donc, là encore, si on devait faire
un forçage psychologique à quelqu'un
sur une note de musique,
on pourrait avoir 85% de chance
d'aller vers le Do et le La.
Ce qui signifie que, si on rajoute
un petit peu de forçage quelconque
par les mots, par de l'hypnose
conversationnelle, par autre chose...
on devrait atteindre un 99%
assez facilement...
Et on arrive à la question suivante :
"Donnez moi une capitale, sans réfléchir".
Alors là !!!
Pooorrrr !
Écrasant !
Il y a eu 26 réponses différentes,
26 villes différentes ont été traitées.
25 villes ne représentent que
7% des réponses.
Je répète pour que vous compreniez
à quel point c'est énorme :
Sur les 26 villes différentes
qui m'ont été données,
25, des villes, ne représentent
que 7% des réponses.
Ce qui veut dire que 93% des réponses
c'était une seule et même ville :
Je vous le donne en mille Émile,
c'était Paris.
Spontanément, apparemment on donne
la capitale du pays dans lequel on habite...
C'est ce qui nous vient
en premier à l'esprit.
Et, de là, je vous ai demandé de me dire
le nom d'un monument célèbre, sans réfléchir.
Alors, je pense qu'il y a un vrai biais
cognitif entre la réponse Paris, précédente
et le monument qui suit derrière.
Ça, ce serait dur à analyser,
il faudrait refaire le test sans qu'il y ait
d'autres questions avant,
parce que les questions peuvent
s'influencer entre elles.
Il peut y avoir, comme ça,
un chemin de pensée
qui est en train de se créer.
Néanmoins, 47% des réponses étaient
la Tour Eiffel
23% pour la Statue de la Liberté
et 22% pour la Tour de Pise !
La Tour de Pise, je ne l'avais
pas vue venir.
Je pensais que l'Arc de Triomphe
serait un peu en avant
ou le Louvre
ou les pyramides d'Égypte
mais non : la Tour de Pise
en troisième.
Et si vous avez fait le compte
pendant que je parlais,
vous vous rendez compte que
TOUTES les autres réponses
ne réprésentaient que
8% des réponses.
Cette petite expérience
nous aura bien montré
qu'on a des shémas de réflexions
et de pensées, à peu près identiques.
En tout cas, pas si variés
qu'on le pense.
Parce que si je prends l'exemple
des monuments célèbres,
on n'était qu'à 11 réponses différentes !
11 réponses sur 65535 personnes
ce n'est pas beaucoup.
Et on a bien un mode de réponse
spontanée un peu prévisible.
Ces réponses là,
toutes ces statistiques,
vous allez pouvoir en faire ce que vous voulez.
Ça peut vous servir, comme je vous le disais,
à améliorer des effets de mentalisme,
à peut-être mieux comprendre
à quel point on peu influencer quelqu'un
en coupant sa réflexion préalable,
ou tout simplement
pour votre culture personnelle.
Alors, j'ai essayé aussi de dégager
peut-être des liens évidents
entre l'âge, entre les suites des réponses,
entre, si quelqu'un aime bien Paris, est-ce qu'il a
tendance à aimer le même film par exemple...
Bon, il n'y avait rien de très intéressant
à en dégager,
mais ça prenait quand même
du temps à faire.
Dans la vidéo que j'ai publiée
juste avant celle-ci,
je vous donnais une petite énigme
vous permettant de tirer
un indice
pour un concours qui
aura lieu bientôt.
Concours que j'annonçais
dans cette vidéo.
Sachez que dans cette vidéo
également
se cache quelque chose
qui vous donnera, encore une fois,
un indice, une avance.
Je vous recommande de ne pas mettre
ce que vous trouvez, dans les commentaires.
Parce que le jour où
l'énigme va sortir
pour gagner ce que vous savez...
Si vous avez décodé les énigmes
préalables, vous aurez de l'avance !
Je ne suis pas sûr que vous ayez
envie de donner de l'avance aux autres...
C'est vous qui voyez, après...
Moi je ne modère pas les commentaires,
vous faites ce que vous voulez.
Si vous êtes encore là à ce stade de la vidéo,
n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air
pour me dire que vous les regardez
en entier et que vous avez aimé.
Et, bien sûr, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
avant de partir. Rendez-vous très bientôt.
Peut-être ce week-end...
Activez la cloche.
Faites ce que vous voulez !
Ciao.
[Musique générique de fin]